I'm so excited I think it's gonna be so
fun I literally don't know how to dance
uh yeah not so fast Christie Brinkley's
time in the ballroom is over before it
even began before Monday night's Dancing
with the Stars season premiere the 65
year old has left the show
ABC released a statement explaining that
Christie hurt herself during rehearsals
and actually has to have surgery on her
wrist and arm she actually shattered her
arm they told me she was rehearsing on
Thursday night she got a feel cut and
you do what everyone does is you take
your arm to go down and she immediately
said I think I've broken out but all is
well that ends well Christie actually
has a special someone coming to take her
place her daughter sailor Brinkley cook
I'm literally about to take off two
minutes to take off and my mom calls me
and she said Taylor you need to save the
day and I was like what do you mean save
the day
sailor sat down with Good Morning
America and explained that she was
actually on a flight to LA to support
her mom on the show when she got the
call I freaked out and I was like I
don't know if I can do this I'm so
scared and then I met with everyone from
Dancing with the Stars and and my
partner and it was I felt this high
just attacking something that I'm so
afraid of seems so incredible to do guys
she had two days to get ready two days
that's bananas so just who is Saylor
Brinkley cook here are seven fast facts
you should know Saylor is 21 years old
she's a photographer who studied at
Parsons School of Design she lives all
over the world splitting her time
between NYC and Australia and now of
course LA for Dancing with the Stars and
get this guy's she's a model just like
her famous mama
[Music]
she even posed nude for Sports
Illustrated you're baring your soul I
mean we're not only naked but we're
having words that we feel describe our
identity to describe who we are and what
we give to the world and just putting
that all out there in one image or in a
set of images and saying all right this
is it you're open for you're open for
interpretation and you're open for
criticism and no one wants that but it's
important to do but didn't tell Christie
beforehand I knew that if I called my
mom she'd be like but Taylor nude so I
took the photos and we did this shoot
and then I sent them to my mom and she
didn't even like ask what it was for
anything she was like oh my god your art
these are beautiful and while she's an
absolute stunner even Saylor has had her
struggles with body image issues I was
looking back at the person that I was
and the insecurities that I did have and
insecurities I do have now in 2017 she
opened up on Instagram explaining quote
I grew up not loving how I looked and
felt held back because of it my body and
I have been through it all but recently
I have been liberated I am healthy I
treat myself well and for that I'm happy
sailor has a super-cute boyfriend named
Ben and number one on our list she's
related to Billy Joel well sort of stick
with me on this one okay before Christie
had Saylor and her brother Jack with ex
Peter cook she had a daughter Alexa ray
Joel with her ex Billy Joel so sailors
have sisters dad is Billy Joel what a
family tree of course et will be here to
fill you in on sailors Dancing with the
Stars journey so make sure to subscribe
to all things et until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]